c'est arrivé par courrier ce matin 577
lettres adressée au députés sur la
légalisation du cannabis des lettres
plus un argument explosif un pétard pour
chaque élu et l'Assemblée nationale a
plongé dans l'illégalité mis à la
poubelle parce que ça ressemble un petit
peu à de la verveine je ne veux pas
tellement la verveine voilà j'ai d'abord
aller à mon bureau pour savoir si j'ai
donc reçu un petit cadeau pour Noël mais
secrétaire rendu arrêter ça au passage
ou qui sait ce que nous allons faire
mais moi je l'ai pas vu l'enveloppe
alors je vais je vais m'enquérir la
provocation a réussi elle vient du
cirque une association qui veut
légaliser le haschich s'amusait à cela
en violation de code pénal ça nécessite
une réaction donc avec
effectivement nous allons déposer
plainte après avoir vérifié que dans ce
joint et bien du cannabis
moi je connais pas